foreign
[Music]
hi and welcome to circuit breakers on
Apple TV plus it's a science fiction
show in the spirit of Twilight Zone so
each episode is like a little mini movie
at its heart it's about the trials and
tribulations that middle schoolers go
through you've got the most passion of
anybody out here but sadly not the
height maybe you should try a sport
you're more suited to right
bowling with a bit of mystery spookiness
and of course technology mixed in
would you like to learn more about this
opportunity yes
yes my episode is about the walking
robot basically taking over my life
I need you to pretend to be me while I
practice dance
sit at my desk do the chores I hate
anything that just gives me more time
what was your plan if you got caught how
would I get caught it looks just like me
yeah but it isn't you
[Music]
in my episode there's a universal remote
that can control our parents we have
pizza and ice cream for dinner as
requested they accidentally pause their
parents because they're frozen who knows
[Music]
what is going on in my episode it's
almost as if time stands still everybody
is Frozen like nobody's moving it's all
silent and it's like super weird and
eerie and creepy I conducted an
experiment in time dilation now how do
you change things back
welcome to memory therapy this is the
TS3 it lets you relive memories
I think I know how to get my parents
back together the pods are technically
time machines and next session I'll load
in more happy memories and they'll
realize how much they love each other
you're dreaming it's not that easy
foreign
told you we shouldn't have done that
something's wrong
[Music]
these electrodes will allow thoughts to
be shared instantaneously in my episode
I volunteered to be in a science
experiment and my and the principal
bodies end up swapping my personality
goes into the 13 year old boy's body and
vice versa I get his transfer completed
just need the doctor to put everything
back to normal let's go then
[Music]
we get introduced to these robots that
can coach your DNA and alter it I can be
genetically altered and increase in my
natural physical strength but these Bots
are very invasive do you know how many
things are wrong with that sense
[Applause]
in this episode we're on Mars taking
experiments for the human race it's
important stuff but
I miss my friends there's like a whole
Sandstorm over my Hub oh no you have to
do whatever it takes for the greater
good
[Music]
we've lost communication with Earth
you get really attached to the
characters and what they're going
through this is not a show about flying
cars this is a show about conflict and
emotion and adventure
[Music]
well you still have to finish the
tension
[Music]